[Music]
[Applause]
always been one of my favorite guests
going back to the mothership steve young
hall of famer espn nfl analyst
three-time super bowl champ paulie do
you have the scouting report on steve
from the combine before i bring him on
yeah back in uh early 80s gil brandt was
taking notes on steve young he listed
him at six foot even in a six foot and
one half inch 205
the 40 yard dash he had from his hand
time was 4.55 seconds for a 40. okay
let's bring in steve young does that
sound right steve four five five for 40.
i i i was faster than that in college uh
gil gil had a slow watch let's be honest
you you knew that and then six foot half
inch
i mean look at my football card dan it
said six two
i mean
the six if you want to know accuracy
look at a football card what i've been
around you you're not six two steve but
football cards don't lie
you know football the funny thing is
football cards is when you when you're
when you start out of the league they
give you a sheet you fill it out and
that's what they use so i wrote down six
too because that's i if you ask me
am i six two i would pass a light editor
test saying yes i am six two
but gil brandt of course thinks that
he's gonna you know shrink me down
because i'm you know i didn't go play
for the cowboys so whatever did you want
to play for the cowboys
roger staubach was my hero who yeah
yeah i mean he was uh roger i mean my
you know you know all the posters you
have in your bedroom and and uh
roger was he had an action picture of
roger i remember it and the ball
uh he started to run and and the ball
was out here and and you could see well
i'm lefty but he was writing and his
hand and fingers on the on the ball were
just you could see it perfectly and i
remember spending hours on i had a ball
and i'd put my fingers and i'd go oh
right there yeah right there
you know it's funny about uh heroes damn
because i remember uh
when i was growing up roger stovak was
super influential to me
i mean
i tried to talk like him i tried to run
like him i
you know and and the thing is
he didn't know me
and it's like people say oh i'm i'm not
responsible for raising your kids or i'm
not responding well i'm trying to pay it
forward for what roger did for me in my
whole life just because i think that
that's
that's my experience so roger was much
more than a poster on the wall that was
for sure but did you think about if if
let's say dallas had the rights
or could have drafted you let's put it
that way would you maybe bypass the usfl
yeah it's possible
yeah i mean i i i you know when
cincinnati had the first pick
and sam weiss came out and told me
they're going to use me for it and i had
john hadel and sid gilman
john don klosterman who had just left
the rams
in la and and and i could go play right
away in la
uh gary zimmerman my buddy that i'd met
on the all-star games was going to be my
right tackle he ended up being a pro
football hall of famer there were so
many guys that were young and really
good players so i really i kind of
believed don klossman and
and sid gilman telling me that he could
teach me how to you know play
quarterback and that was some big stuff
and rather than just go sit behind ken
anderson or whatever they were going to
do i i but if it was dallas yeah i
i think that might have won the day
is there a bias against left-handed
quarterbacks
yeah there has to be dan i mean
i mean just just the numbers
i mean there's ten percent of the
countries left-handed and zero percent
of quarterbacks in the nfl are
left-handed other than now two uh showed
up after five or six years of nobody
um but what's the difference on the
field though steve
the difference is an advantage
everything in football is right-handed
every coach puts up the play
right-handed every play is run
right-handed first
um
right everything is right-handed so
lefty i always felt like
you know uh it was it was like
linebackers would you know they were you
could see that they were like well you
know they weren't sure where you know
it's just a little bit of an advantage
and i but i remember mike in college uh
doug scoble was my uh offensive
coordinator at byu and and a freshman
and he didn't know my name i was like
eighth string he saw me in like november
of my freshman year at the end of the
season
i ran into him and he said hey young and
i was like oh he knows my name and he
goes uh you know by the way i don't
coach lefties
and
i was like
well
so much for that
that was not that's not what i'd heard
and uh but he was serious but he ended
up going to san diego state a month
later and ted tolner came in to run the
offense and uh
and he was and i i'd moved to defense
because uh lavell edwards would move me
over there because couldn't coach
lefties wait wait wait wait
you're a defensive back
for about for about two weeks in january
in winter meetings tom holmoe
was the defensive captain and he was
teaching me how to back pedal and i and
because they said look you're you're
fast you're four five five
uh
you could you could go tackle everybody
and so i was like all right i guess i
have no choice
and then ted toner came when i was i
kept throwing the football because i was
loving learning how to throw it really i
jim mcmahon had shown me how to how to
release the ball and really put power on
it i never really learned in high school
and then when i learned that i was like
i just want to throw the football i can
it's amazing how it feels and what i
could do and i could put it right there
you know and ted tolner said why are you
why did you move to defense i go because
i'm lefty
what are you an idiot what do you mean
no they told me i couldn't play a
quarterback because i was lefty and he
goes that's stupid he went into
salavella and then next he said look i
negotiated
uh for spring ball
for four weeks of spring ball the first
two weeks you're gonna play quarterback
and um
and if that doesn't work out then you go
back to defensive back and by the end of
the two weeks i was backing up jim
mcmahon and there you have it so lefty's
left but there is definite there has to
be dan a bias
against lefties because there's just no
there's none around that's just crazy
but i also wonder when you think of a
lefty we normally don't think that they
have great velocity
you know i it feels like they have touch
they have touch
you know kenny stabler had no i'm just
saying well
look you've got a sample size of three
you michael vick could throw it
like michael vick could throw it okay i
get you a shane um
i i gotta i mean
look i understand it's like not a
fastball out there but uh for getting
the job done and i mean joe montana
even you know tom brady
peyton manning i mean there's not a
fastball in there right now right so i
don't know what you're looking for the
jeff george no no no no i'm not did i
justify you
i just the bias as well i see
you're part of the problem you're not
part of the solution no wow
my apology
my apologies i i'm sorry to all
left-handed quarterbacks out there i
apologize
you can see i'm not i'm not
emotional it no
do you do you toss the ball when's the
last time you actually
played catcher threw the ball last night
with justin jefferson and randy moss
well i i mean for like
you missed me dancing
do you watch sports dan what i don't
know if you we're the where the pre-game
show of record i don't know why you
would miss that what show are you on
oh you're on that fox show yeah monday
night
monday night espn monday night yeah i
can't believe that that is just
disrespectful
you hate lefties i can i do i but you
know i know what montana's doing
[Laughter]
yeah i backed you in the corner you had
to come out shooting with both guns and
you're like i know i know what could i
do i know my dog's got me in the corner
now where do i go i just gotta if i got
a fire i kind of fired hard as i can
how close did jim mcmahon come to
getting tossed out of byu
not i mean
i i remember
lavellid was just a masterful
human being he he
he was a he was a phenomenal human he
could he could he could see the good in
people he could he could work the the
system and give people opportunities and
jim mcmahon he i remember calling in jim
and saying jim
man come on like if you're going to
throw a party like that you got to do it
you can't do it in provo man you got to
go to parks
and uh jim's like yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay yeah yeah
and uh but he just
lavelle saw the good in everybody and
jim had a lot of good he was a funny
good guy he was crazy
but he was a he was a he was a good
human and uh byu's better for having him
around so uh but i did see some things
i've never seen ever since by the way
people always say what's the wildest
thing you've ever seen in your life or
where were you where were you i was like
i was in provo utah
and what did you see
uh let's not uh i i
let's just leave it that day that jim
mcmahon threw some uh some crazy stuff
but you didn't go to the parties did you
i popped in i popped in i was invited i
popped in
it always checked it out i just checked
it out i thought holy cow did you ever
hear dion talking about when he first
got to the cowboys
and mike michael irvin was throwing a
party at hotel suite
and dion shows up
and he says
mike i i don't do that stuff
i don't live like this and he and he
turned around and walked out of the
hotel
room dion you know dion is a
i remember him joining the 49ers and and
uh everyone was worried about what kind
of teammate dion would be and because no
one knew him really well because he'd
been in atlanta
and new is a phenomenal football player
but not sure about a teammate and he
walked in and he said look steve i am a
master class uh pr guy
so don't be fooled i know what i'm doing
there
but don't ever don't don't pay attention
don't don't get involved in it
uh i'm going to be the best teammate you
ever had
and i remember that's a heck of a
statement and it was true i was like
just don't pay attention all the stuff
going on
i'm going to take the blo in the locker
room i got your back i'm going to i'm
i'm and he was he was a phenomenal
teammate
very underrated
uh locker room guy he was he was an
amazing amazing football player and an
amazing amazing kind of
uh athlete and i'm not just athlete
physically like an emotional
uh athlete like he could be
you know go go do the
dion thing and then he could he could
you know he could do two things at once
he could be a phenomenal uh you know
teammate and he could be out there doing
his you know kind of marketing maven
stuff but i wonder though with the
emphasis on offense if if dion is coming
up now
is he
a wide receiver
well what about the kid he just dropped
he just got signed i mean you know what
he told him you know look i i
i the same kind of thing i mean dion's
very influential and he's the kid's
going to play defensive back when it
sounds like he's the great one of the
great athletes of all time why did he
play receiver
i in fact i funny you answer that
question dan just the other day i was
asking i said to myself when he when he
signed the kid uh uh i'm sorry for
remember i can't remember his name but
travis hunter
travis so he goes to goes to jackson
state i mean i was trying to think of
how dion sold him and i could i could
sit there i could hear him selling him i
could hear how good he was how good he
would be and how he could tell him you
know all the things that get him to come
to jackson state can you imagine being
the number one recruit going to georgia
or florida state or and they said no no
no
i'm going to jackson state yeah i mean
that how good you want to honor all good
diana's right there well it's it's
really dsu it's deion sanders university
he's he's going to play for dion and if
dion happens to get another job
it feels like that's a package deal
yeah but it's pretty cool
what uh historically black college is
what dion's doing for those schools yeah
i mean it's not just one school it feels
like dion's
you know kind of
leading the way for 10 schools which is
pretty
i'm i guess i'm making my point for you
yeah as i continue to talk about dion
he's quite quite a human um you know i
was watching you break down justin
fields that he tries to do too much oh
now you're going to say you watch the
show even though you don't even know
where okay i see her going so i did
watch that you did you did break down
justin fields right and you said that he
was trying too hard uh young
quarterbacks try too hard what advice
would you give justin fields
uh the advice i give any what i'll call
dual threat quarterbacks that are good
runners who can throw
uh they've gotta they've gotta graduate
to throwers who can run
and the job in the nfl is to throw the
football in the pocket how long did it
take you
it's a process but it's more of an i'm
telling you
sid gilman would go back to the usfl one
of the best things he ever did was you
know i'd run around and make plays and
you know run for first downs and he like
what the hell what are you doing you no
one knows where you're going no one
knows what you're doing knowing what
stand in there and throw the football
and i'm like what do you mean standing
through the football i'm not gonna take
a sack and you know i can go run around
and make something happen what are you
talking about he goes you don't
understand we call play in the huddle
the play matters
stuff matters you got to get it to get
at the
full measure of the play
you leave too early
and so one time i ran around and he got
irritated let's go get a rope someone
give me a rope someone got a jump rope
or something that was running around he
goes he got a rope he stopped practice
he tied my legs
together
you know it was more ceremonial you know
what i mean but he was like telling me
what i would want to tell justin fields
what i would want to tell michael vick
which i did tell michael vick what i
would tell anybody who could
run around and throw the football
you have to
you have to be like mac jones
mac jones is not going anywhere
mac jones has to
figure out a way to be a phenomenal
sophisticated throw the football from
the pocket
and you have to be mac jones for
some time
so that you can
you know i'm not saying mac jones is
going to be spectacular i'm just saying
you have to be the guy that can't move
you have to you have to tie your legs up
you know kind of mentally so that you
actually are forced to sit in there and
figure out how to get the ball out of
the pocket like out of your hand
and i think once you start to learn that
game and
you can run around
that's when the danger really comes i
mean that's when people
you know i see the young
guys and and josh allen and patrick
mahomes and
and they're
they're getting there
and it's gonna
you can see how dangerous they are and
uh
um it's funny patrick mahomes this year
really the challenge was the league as
what happened to us uh with the west
coast offense in the early 90s it was so
far ahead of everybody defenses finally
said forget it
screw it we're not we're just going to
play zone we're just going to back up
we're going to give you everything short
but we're not going to get beat with you
throwing all over the place and people
running around we're spinning around
we're not going to do that we're going
to put 22 eyeballs on the quarterback
and we're just going to wait
and force you to be patient force you to
not make mistakes and won't force you to
go you know
9 10 11 12 play drives
you can do it all day long but you got
to show the patience and that's what the
chief that's what happened the chiefs
this year defenses said you know what
screw it we're not travis kelsey running
all over the place
uh tyreek hill running the no more
just back up and force you to plea you
know be be
you know human just drop it off and they
struggled patrick struggled a little bit
yeah but they they faced the challenge
or remember was it late october they
were losing games or maybe it was middle
october you know like who are the chiefs
what's going on well the league said no
more
and they had to adjust and then they did
and now the leak has no answer i think
the chiefs are better today
more dangerous today than they've ever
been because
they now have all the arrows in the
quiver that they needed the defenses go
oh we can we have no answer now i got to
start watching this espn stuff it thinks
steve is really breaking some stuff down
here could you outrun brady right now
yes okay yes tom
tom's a good man a good friend but uh
tom what i love about tom uh well i mean
obviously amazing and so many things
how do you get started but one of the
things i love is when he rarely does
throw an interception a pick six and and
tom is super competitive as you know
like hype i mean white hot
super competitive but his his body turns
to try to go clean up his mess because
he
he means to right and he starts to run
to do it he's like
[Laughter]
why bother
nobody's that slow that i'll catch him
and i guess i mean if we can i just take
one minute and and tip my cap to the
great tom brady because not only has he
done what he's done but he's done it
from one spot like i didn't have to do
that
and there's a lot of guys that don't
have to do that and that is it i mean
peyton manning had to do it from one
spot dan marino had to do it from one
spot
um
that is not a i would not want to live
that way i wouldn't blame the play in
the playing the position and not being
able to get around a little bit
man i just how do you i just think it's
amazing what they've done i want to uh
let you plug what you're doing uh you're
the chairman of the board of integrity
and your uh gifting employees oh you're
a good man
yeah go ahead so go ahead give give the
plug well no i mean
look i
it's funny they uh i have i've
transitioned 20 years ago and now i've
been in private equity for longer than i
played football and one of our
businesses integrity's insurance
business and it's called tech insurer
and what they've done is all that they
they sit in between the carriers and the
and the insurance agents with pr they
create products for senior living and
it's really i mean you think you say
it's a business and it's but it's a good
cool business and but not only that it's
good people and brian adams runs the
business uh for us and uh
he came to me a couple years ago and he
said steve i i want to i want to give
equity to the employees i want to make
him owners of this business
and i remember when he did it i thought
you know
because i've been i've watched the nfl
for years dan and you can you know this
because you're older you're old enough
to remember
there was days back in the 80s and 90s
where
like players and and owners were
like miles apart
nobody
there was like i remember in 1987 when
we went on strike i want to say was the
owner of the giant somebody said well
don't they understand the players we're
the owners and they're the chattel
and i remember thinking i went to law
school bro i know what chattel is and
that's not cool like that that does not
that is not cool but it was a guy like
eddie bartolo who finally said you know
what i want you as my partner
i want you as a part of my family and
and then robert kraft and and and uh
arthur blank and our guys started to own
teams that were like look i i want to
build a partnership with with players
and in doing that i think the cva
finally kind of caught up to that in the
early 2000s and you want to know why the
league is so great today you can say all
kinds of things i says because owners
finally gave
essentially profit sharing to the
players so when brian said that to me
i said that's a great idea because when
people feel like they're owners they
they'll
they'll do anything
because they feel like they're they're
actually a part of this
and so he did it and that's he's not i
don't know if there's any insurance
company in the world that does this but
he started he gave uh 50 million dollars
out two years ago to get started on this
program and then we just finished
another transaction with silver lake
egon durban the famous gun durbin and uh
and and now those guys those that those
employees 5 500 employees
now who had a stake in the business have
now made 150 125 million dollars still
with their stake i mean they're still
making and and so yes it's a great way
to give people a chance to feel that
sense of ownership and it's also a great
place for companies and so i guess the
point that we came on the show to be
honest with you dan is that people
there's a lot of people that own
businesses i i suggest highly suggest
you think about making employees owners
of your business and start to share and
that's a great it was a good example to
me to be honest with you so there's
that's the story and you know i
appreciate you
give me a second to talk about him it's
great to talk to you and i'm going to
start watching that football program
that you're in great daniel i love being
on with you you asked me great questions
i could go on for an hour and laugh with
you and i appreciate it and so
uh anytime my best to the family how
many kids now
four i remember college you remember
when you had your first and then i think
you said why didn't you tell me what
this was like yeah see you see another
thing you hid from me i i i wish i had
five or six i mean i feel like i got you
know i started late and
i mean these kids are amazing so i mean
they're teaching me more i i have you
know a couple athletes and a couple of
ones in music theater wants to be on
broadway i mean i was like
all right you can sing like
how do you you can sing no one can sing
no one can sing in my family for
generations i mean
you're new to ancestry.com and there is
no
singing genes
anywhere there's no connection but the
kid can sing
awesome well hey great to talk to you
again thanks and uh merry christmas
buddy
you too merry christmas all right we'll
take a break back after this